Mình bà thông ba đã giải thích cao phụ chách chính xe đừng quả của lým mình cho ông E.U.
Mà cả hạ cá lác kêu của mình bà is rent chấm giúp dùng đồ viên,
đông thời cho biết khổ này đang tham vận cái nước chúng đông giằm tiêm dại pháp ngoại giao.
Thất biểu với hẳng thúc tận rồi tờ để buồn sèo,
Mà cá lác sẽ mạnh việc chấm giúp chiến sự là ở trong,
đông thời kẻng báo dùng đồ có mỹ cửa vật tầm kiểm soát.
Mòi gá bà nó ở uống giả đông, mấy cho chúng dàng để đưa các bên chở lại bằng đàn phán.
Mò dù i ra đã hất tự khả năng xuống thác xuống đột,
lên quan tự ở bên hông một bà cho biết cho ông Utien giả không phải rao nhầm đảm bảo từng gió hàng 2,
thay vì trên khai lực lộn quân sự như đẹp nghi của phía Mỹ.
Sư thật là như nước cho ông cũng đã tự cho đề xuất của Mỹ về việc yêu trên hạc,
cho rằng không sẵn sàng đưa viên xí và phủng trên sự.
Theo bà cá lác, E.U. không hoàn toàn hiểu một số quy định của Washington trong cuộc sống đồ hiện nay,
sau đã quen với sự khó đoán từ chính quyền của tổng thống đồ đang trăm.
Chào mùa dễ bị linh quan, hả thủ tổn rời tờ dân các ngon tìm Mỹ cho biết
Washington vốn đã được cạnh bảo chứa rằng việc tấn công i raan có thể dẫn tới phản những trạy đối nhằm và các đồng mình vùng bình
vàng, vui cơ xung đồ đàn giọt, họ kinh pháp.